[Music]
if you were born in the late 90s
and into the 2000s your ecosystem is
climate change is going to kill us all
the government hates you and is trying
to kill you the health care system wants
to kill you and murder you and they
don't have humans to walk through that
with them we've just handed them cell
phones
[Music]
it's nine o'clock on a saturday
regular crowd shuffles in hey it's the
dr john deloney show what is going on
it's not even saturday maybe it is but
probably it's not
i'm so glad you're here i'm john and we
are getting into the messy lives of
other people on the best mental health
show
ever
ever we're talking about relationships
mental health school
work whatever's going on in your hearts
and minds and if you want to be on the
show give me a call at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 hold on someone's taking
my picture out in the lobby i'll just
wave what's up all right cool very cool
all right let's go to katie in fort
wayne what's up katie how we doing
i'm good how are you doctors dr delany
you just call me john good good good
what's up
well i have a little bit of a more broad
question but i think it's something that
a lot of listeners can relate with
so i work at an after school program
with middle school students so they're
between 11 and 13
and
the large majority of them bring in a
lot of emotional baggage and trauma so i
guess my overarching question is how do
we come alongside them and meet kids
where they are
and help them work through their trauma
in a way that they can trust us
oh that's so hard
that's
that's a lot um
right out of the gate i want to tell you
that's a tall order that i i might shift
the focus there um it's very hard in
your limited one hour a day or one and a
half hours a day
in
three months if you will to
take a child's brain that's being
traumatized
on the regular by the very people who
are supposed to love and connect
and give that bring peace and healing so
that that kid can drop his shoulders and
breathe and his body can stop going to
war and then he can start practicing
relationships
that's hard
um right out of the gate the firs the
most important thing i could tell you is
to absolutely stone love those kids
yeah and love those kids like
stop them when they walk in the building
and make them come to you or you go to
them and you look them in the eyes and
if you're allowed to
hold their hands or hold their face and
say i love you i'm so glad that you're
here
this place is better when you're here
and this is not a one-time fix this is
an every day week after week month after
one to year after year
and their bodies will learn that place
is safe she's safe
see what i'm saying
and that's so hard the trauma healing
can't be done in an after after school
program it's going to be a piece of a
larger healing picture right
i guess along with that idea of the
larger healing picture
we are
mandatory reporters we do have frequent
contact with gps and whatnot so how do
we
communicate that people like cps or
counselors that the school has
connections to the kids with different
things like that how do we
present that in a way that is harmful
because a lot of these kids
have told us that gps only makes
everything worse and whatnot so how do
we
i guess
show that people are trying to be
advocates for them
you have to build trust outside of the
event
outside of the moment right it's um
i'm trying to think of an example like
i have lived my life in a way and done
my life in a way and supported people in
in front of in front of
on stages and behind closed doors in a
way that if somebody accused me of x y
or z
it would be obnoxious
right because people would go no
their default setting in these areas
would be trust now if somebody came
forward and said hey uh this guy made a
really inappropriate diarrhea joke and a
funeral everyone would go yeah i could
probably see that that was really not
cool right i would not have the benefit
of the doubt on that right
but when it comes to something some big
egregious thing
people's default setting would be no way
right and so
trying to win the battle of
uh here's a great example this one's
hard
i was working with a kid at a
center that dealt with traumatized
children and i was giving a trauma
assessment to this child
and it was in fact the brother and
sister we're doing it with we're doing
it together and it's it's like uh
it's like a tfcbt intake form and we're
trying to gauge the aces and we're
trying to gauge like where they are
and how much trauma they've experienced
when they came here and this was a
really important moment i was with dr
robinson and she is an important mentor
for me where she was watching me do this
and so i did the intake and their trauma
score was basically zero
and their their parents had left i mean
it was maybe one or two their parents
had left them and their their
grandparents were now taking over and
granddad got in trouble got a dwi or
something like that
and
then the house got stormed like police
officers showed up it was a big whole
thing they took the kids out put them in
a van and took them out
and i looked at the trauma scores not
what i was expecting because usually
when i did it they were relatively high
and i looked at her and she looked at me
and said
and now their trauma begins
today
their trauma begins now and i was like
oh they're going to be worse off because
of the system we overstepped
we being our community overstepped
and the answer was yes right so we took
kids that were their lives looked very
different than ours but it was a mess
and then we stormed their house dragged
them out of their house put them in a
car and then dropped them off at a
residential treatment center
and now they're going oh no right you
see what i'm saying so
you have to earn trust for these kids
and understand that cps might have shown
up and made everything worse and worse
than their mind is they took my mom away
they took my dad away and they don't
have the wisdom and the context to know
your mom was hurting your mom was an
addict your dad was struggling your mom
was struggling they don't know that they
just know because that person came in my
house kicking and screaming or yelling
i don't get to see my mommy anymore
and there's nothing you can say to that
other than i'm so so sorry
i know you miss your mom right so on the
other side of that you can show up every
day tell them that you love them you can
play pool with them you can ask them how
their homework's going you can hold them
accountable which is a huge thing
you're not allowed to talk that way here
if you choose to talk that way here you
are choosing to leave and i don't like
that because this place can't work
without you same as i talk to my kids
right
so that when you say i have to make this
phone call because it's in your best
interest they're gonna kick and scream
and be mad but they're gonna trust you
you get what i'm saying
yeah for sure and that's so hard i know
do you think that the aspect of
accountability
is
bigger than
like the idea of
like doing something on their behalf
almost like
holding them to that higher level or
helping them like slowly change their
behavior and their reaction is bigger
than
maybe like
calling cps like in the long run like
what will make the bigger difference in
their life well cps is going to protect
the children from
adults in their lives who are not living
up to their responsibilities
yeah
accountability is going to be
this is who we are and this is how we
talk to one another and we don't hit and
we don't swear at adults and we don't
lose our temper and if we do need to
take a break so you're what you're
trying to do is can is give them a gap
the more traumatized the person is the
the thinner the gap is between stimulus
and response
between
you just came at me i'm firing back
because i've not fired back before and
it's gotten me hurt
or my mom's about to leave because you
took my mom away i'm coming the hell's
coming with me right i'm coming swinging
because you took my mom away
and what we're trying to do in those
moments what love does what connection
doesn't know it sounds so cheesy but
it's true
it provides a little bit of a gap
between the stimulus and the response
and that's what we're trying to teach
these kids yes somebody just stepped to
you
breathe
is it worth not being able to be around
me and your friends
is it worth going to
in school suspension is it worth going
to jail no the answer is always no
right and so what we're trying to do is
build that gap there um
so the cps and accountability are going
to be two different conversations
usually
yeah
how are you doing
this is a hard hard hard thing
i'm good i think that
learning how to navigate
the conversations with the kids has
helped me
navigate a lot of similar conversations
in my own life which has been really
influential like getting a love on these
kids has taught me how to help
family problems or just my own personal
life and so
slowly but surely we're getting there i
think that's awesome so one of the
things i wish i could go back and do
differently is this uh when i worked
similar jobs i worked at camps i've
worked at day camp summer camp kind of
things i've worked at with all different
groups right so
similar um i've never worked at the
particular group a youth center but
similar
[Music]
i really overshot the mark and what i
mean by this is i was using these kids
as a way to quote-unquote change the
world
to affect the system i want things to be
different at a global level and then a
national level than a state level in a
community level
and i wish i could go back and do that
over
the way you change things at a global
national level is you love really
intensely at the local level
yeah so instead of i want to give your
heart peace right now because you're
doing a hard hard job i'm so grateful
you're in your community doing this in
fort wayne what i want you to to begin
to do is to walk into this building and
we're not trying to solve global
problems i'm trying to love these 14
kids as deeply as i possibly can in the
hour and a half that i got them
yeah
does that make sense it takes a lot of
bricks out of your backpack you're not
carrying the weight of the world on your
shoulders you're carrying the love of
these 14 kids
yeah and and before they get there i'm
going to write them each a letter i'm
going to hand it to them before they go
because they're going to hold something
for that they got for me that just says
i love you i'm so glad i got to be with
you today right little things like that
change family trees
because they're gonna have for the first
time in their life
they're gonna have a picture of what
love is we have a picture of what
connection is they're gonna have a
picture of fill in the blank right and
by the way not all these kids
parents are terrible some of them are
just working a lot right they're trying
to they're trying to figure out life and
they got great parents
who are duct taping four and five jobs
together just trying to put food on the
table because everything's so expensive
um and so they don't have terrible
whatever but they can find connection
and love in you
that's hard hard hard
and those kids are suffering huh
yeah it's
it's i think it's slowly gotten worse
too like
just the
quality and the quantity of
abuse and trauma and the bricks that
those kids are carrying in and i think
that
covid and just the whole quarantine in
the school system has just
made everything so different so working
through that's been challenging yeah
well i'm so grateful you're there it's
it's we'll be working through that for
years and years and years um that's
going to ripple through our communities
for
i don't like it and i'm glad you're
there i'm glad you're there katie um for
everybody working with
and in the lives of young people whether
you're a teacher whether you're a social
worker whether you are working at an
after care program or weekend program or
big brothers program
seek connection first
seek how do i plug into this kid first
and how do i make this kid
feel
safe peace
we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and then
i'll try to upsell you a bunch of
nonsense that's going to hurt you down
the road and most importantly when
you're making this big life change you
can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back
listen if you're about to buy a home and
make a big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we're back hey along the lines
of that last call james he
gave me this uh survey right before the
show started
it's uh by miranda dixon
lunenburg
is
i think it's published at vox here
says the mental health million project
queried over 220 000 people on
well-being across the world and it
writes the results are worrying
one standout finding was a worrying
decline in mental well-being in the 18
to 24 year old age bracket this is a
surprise because usually they're at a
u-shaped curve right people are feeling
better for most of their life
with the youngest and oldest groups
fearing best and people in middle age
are like is this what my life is
and
they're concerned because on the front
end of this scale the numbers are
are terrifying
says that while concerns about the state
of youth mental health have been growing
in the u.s
that four in 10 adolescents reported
feeling persistently sad and hopeless
this is a global issue
global issue
and we'll talk about this in another
episode we had a planning meeting the
other day we talked about we'll talk
about this
just for a second
think about what we've done to these
kids
and this isn't just i mean the pandemic
made it way worse no make no mistake it
made it
um locking these kids down not being
able to see each other knowing that
their grandmothers were dying alone in a
hospital and they said to watch it
happen on zoom like all these things
were we're torturing young people
and i'm not even gonna say we didn't
need to do it i'm not doing all that
it's we tortured young people
but before that
these kids have grown into an ecosystem
when if you were born in the 70s 80s
even into the 90s
you were born into a narrative
of we can do anything we can change the
world we can solve all these things we
can go to the we just got back from the
moon what's next right let's go to
these kids if you were born in the late
90s
and into the 2000s your ecosystem is
climate change is going to kill us all
tomorrow
the government hates you and is trying
to kill you
your teachers are stupid and they're
moronic and they're terrible and they're
ruining everything the health care
system wants to kill you and murder you
terrorists are trying to kill you and
murder you at every turn
countries are just going to lob grenades
and roll tanks into each other's
neighborhoods and but that's their world
and they don't have humans to walk
through that with them we've just handed
them cell phones
and so if you go and look at some of the
great research on kids who have grown up
in war zones
it's the human connection like how are
they even functioning it's because they
have people
and there's a physiological balancing of
this teeter-totter of pain and
connection
that keeps a kid stable and whole and
these kids do not have this at a global
level
this article goes on to say the trend
was already present before the cove 19
pandemic but worsened significantly
between 2019 and 2020 one factor is
truly universal rising smartphone use
and internet access is crushing these
little people they speculate the key
factor may not be the internet itself
it's not i love watching videos with my
kids they're funny
but it's the statistics that suggest
that they seem to spend or that they
spend an average of seven to ten hours a
day
online
at the global level young people are
spending seven to ten hours a day online
which crowds out in-person interaction
which is the key to building a strong
social self
i think a lot of the unrest in conflict
may be
related to because at the age of 18 you
have the same experience of interacting
with people as a seven or eight year old
in the past
18 year olds have the same social
connective tissue as a seven and eight
year old from the past we've stunted
them by a decade by handing them
computers and i also want to point this
out
i had a hard conversation with my son
and um i'll just be this high level as i
can
uh but he came at me pretty good and
he's in middle school and he came at me
his right to do so and i gave him
permission to do so
but he said dad you're telling the whole
world no cell phones and i'm not allowed
to have any cell phones and fine i get
that social media is blah blah blah
but dad because you've made this rule
and here is his quote i have no one
i don't even want to text
i don't know when the birthday parties
are i don't know when all the guys are
getting together for whatever
and i ever thought about that my wife
and i thought about it and we used to
have the phone on the wall in the
kitchen right we could had the curly
little cord to it and we could call each
other and find out what was going on
and he's it's gone it's gone
so here's what i need here's what i'm
asking i'm asking for a group of parents
to step up and say let's change the way
we're doing this let's not hand every
kid a cell phone and let's figure out
ways that we as adults can communicate
because i'm not gonna hand my kid poison
i'm not gonna hand him a loaded weapon
and say make good choices young man i'm
not gonna do that and at the same time
he's looking at me saying dad i get this
and i'm completely and totally alone
what do i do and that's one of the few
times in my own home i don't have a good
answer
i don't know
i don't know
but i know that
wealth doesn't matter countries and
cultures assume
the us uk ireland canada australia and
new zealand
had the worst scores of mental health
a culture where we each for ourselves
and judged and sorted by performance may
be good for economic growth but damaging
to our collective well mental well-being
we've got to do things differently
and these are the kids showing up to
katie's after-school program and saying
can you help me please
oh what a mess what a mess what a mess
all right let's go to sauna and see how
it all stopped there let's go to sana
what's up sana
hi dr john thanks so much for taking my
call you bet what's up
um
so well first i just want to say like
i know you call yourself a knucklehead a
lot and this morning i heard you like
kind of take that back you're working on
the positive self-talk i'm trying i'm
trying
i just want you to know that like what
you are doing is so important because
there's so many of us who grew up in
situations where we just have no concept
of what healthy
relationship healthy communication looks
like and i've personally gone through
some counseling for that but i know that
there's a lot of people that like
watching their show they're like
starting to make those connections for
the first time so thank you so much for
that well thank you love i'm grateful
for your kindness i really appreciate
that
um yeah so what's up how can i help
yeah so i'm calling because
um my husband has severe misophonia no
no really
yeah is it for real or is it just um
is it just kind of like yeah yeah you
know what i mean like people just throw
that around social media is it for real
yeah no it's it's for real like it's not
you know like
yeah i know like you hear people on on
social media saying like oh i hate the
sound of people chewing it's like no
like this is like actually like a
like a daily struggle for him
like he um okay let me just let me tell
everybody what this is so misophonia is
yeah it is um
oh gosh it's the worst the worst
sounds repetitive clicking noises
chewing sometimes people's voices um
little little things that most of us
don't hear on a daily basis are we here
and can tune out
the last i read on it there's some sort
of connection between that and a
fight-or-flight response
something connected to movement there's
just like a it's like a shortcut in the
brain that is a it's a shortcut to the
wrong place right
and it's like trying to take a shortcut
to chick-fil-a and you end up at burger
king like we got to a restaurant that's
the wrong one
and
the smallest thing can send a body into
a panic or into a rage it's just this
const in this little like
or
or whatever whatever like the way people
say certain words can make
it it's annoying to us it is
severely debilitating for folks and so
the reason why i asked you is it real is
no none of us like to have somebody
chewing gum in our ear right and it can
be like that gross whatever
um
but there are others that it's it's a
totally different physiological
experience you're telling me your
husband's full-on right
it's it it's really bad
for him man
yeah he um
so like it's it's a daily struggle he
the way he describes it is like
you know once once he hears the sound
and it's the littlest things like i'm
i have like mild to moderate hearing
loss so some of the things i physically
can't even perceive and they are driving
him nuts um but like once once he hears
the sound it's like it
he said he gets all this pent-up energy
and it's like he needs to leave the room
he needs to get away from it or like he
says he'll get um
all of this energy like stuck in his jaw
and there have been times that he's like
bit in his own arm or he'll
um if he can't get away from it he's
like scratched himself
so my my physiology may be off okay so
yeah for you endocrinologists who listen
to this and let's be honest there's a
bunch of them not really um
like i may be off here
my understanding which is very very
limited i'm in no way an expert on this
is that it there is a connection between
the auditory signaling system and the
fight-or-flight response and so think
about that energy that he feel that the
way he's describing that is the is a
perfect way i've i've i understand it
and again i may be wrong i'm not a
neuroscientist but
that his body will flood with adrenaline
cortisol fight-or-flight chemicals his
body is ready for a fistfight his body
is ready to take off sprinting for its
life and he's sitting there at the
dinner table with his in-laws just
chewing right and so
yeah there's this toggle between
go now
and
dude be cool man that's your wife's
parents chill chill chill right and it
just it's it it's maddening right it's
maddening
yeah oh and you have you have hearing
loss and you're like i don't have no
idea what's happening here
oh
that is the worst sauna oh man okay so
how can i help i'm so sorry
yeah so um he
basically so he
his job right now he's
in a car with his co-worker for a lot of
the day driving from job site to job
site um and so
by the end of the day he's already like
you know at a certain stress level from
from doing with that all day
and
then uh it's the worst
uh my some of my own speech sounds are
triggering to him
on that
i swear like four or five days a week
he's like i just want to be able to hear
my wife talk
um
it's
like we can't we can't even pray
together without it
like just ruining the
you know the time together um
and so i
i guess i have a couple of things one
like
how do we cope with those moments like
we know
we know a little bit of sign language
and we're kind of like learning more out
of necessity just because it's so
frequent yeah um but then we run into
like the frustration of not being able
to fully express ourselves too yeah um
and then so like how do we cope with
that and like the
you know we will be having a perfectly
good time and then all of a sudden it's
like a brick wall
dropping
you know
and then the other thing is like for me
personally like
you know we want to have kids someday
and i'm like
really worried like how are we gonna
handle that if we can barely like get
through
like just talking to each other some
days you know yeah absolutely those are
all super real thank you for sharing
that
yeah
all right so
again i'm gonna preface this i'm not an
expert at this has he gone to see a
doctor before
um
no so when he was in high school uh he
had a psychiatrist who wasn't very
helpful and medicated him for anxiety
and i think that
they you know i don't know that they
listened very well because that wasn't
the problem um and so we're looking for
a counselor
i would start with a medical doctor
actually
yeah i would start with a medical doctor
um i don't know
what
pharmacological interventions look like
here um but there may be and so i that's
where i would start
and i would be super open super honest
but i would be i would that's where i
would start i wouldn't start with a
counselor there's going to be some
relational things y'all got to work
through and i'll talk you through a
couple of those now but i would start
there so um
you mentioned it and i'm glad you
mentioned it the way you did
this is going to be a both and situation
one he has to own
own own he has to own
his global wellness ecosystem
he's got to give his body a chance to
not if but when things
set off his alarm systems
he's got some resilience there that may
mean he's got to have a different job
this is just the way think of this as or
let me put this at he's not making this
up
okay
and for you to not be able to see it and
to just want to say hey i love you and
for that to be what sends your husband
into a panic it's disorienting and it's
it right it's it's really
awful
so i want to tell you if it's real it's
real and it is
nobody wants this man if people feel
like they're losing their minds right
like they go to war with their heads
um
uh
he has to be responsible so i want you
to think of this as though he lost a
foot or he is have some mobility
challenges he's in a wheelchair for a
season like what would you have to you'd
have to do things very very differently
you couldn't just kind of limp through
your normal regular life everything's
different now and so i want you to think
about or him to think about
is he exercising is he sleeping is he
eating right is he reducing his overall
inflammatory response
is he he may have to wear headphones in
the car he may have to tell his
co-worker hey this is ridiculous but i
can't talk in the car um or i've got to
wear these headphones like he's got to
be start being very open and advocating
for himself the same as if he worked at
a place that didn't have a wheelchair
ramp and suddenly he found himself with
mobility issues okay that very simple
yeah
um and he's gonna have to be brave about
it he's gonna have to suck it up and do
it and this sucks and it's hard but
that's just what we got to do
the second thing is is you
are gonna have to
this is hard you're gonna have to
continue to lean into different ways to
communicate or y'all are gonna have to
come up with some signals or some
gentle ways to lean into one another in
a different way
and i know that's frustrating for you
that's frustrating for him it's
frustrating for everybody
and that's where y'all are
and that might mean that he's going to
wear earplugs and so you're going to
have to talk a little bit louder and but
it'll take some of the sharpness off
it'll take some of that um that burn
that happens when when you say the like
the vowels or the continents in the
wrong way right is that is that is that
what it is it's usually pieces of words
yeah it's it's usually the consonant
okay all right so um
it might be that you're gonna start
working with a vocal coach and i have to
work with a vocal coach because i talk
so much literally um it may mean that
i'm going to y'all going to continue to
lean into it instead of this being like
a beating you're going to lean into
becoming super fluent in american sign
language or whatever the sign language i
want to do we're gonna we're gonna do
some of these things
because our life is super different now
i would also recommend
try a weekend babysitting job aft not
now but
wait for a couple of months when he's
got his wellness under control when
y'all are working on different ways to
communicate
um and then i want you all to have a
friend let you keep their kid for a
weekend or an in-law a relative let you
keep their kid for a weekend and you can
begin to practice
because this isn't going to be whether
he loves his kid of course he is and
whether he loves you of course he is
this is going to be
will his body allow him to have a child
in the house
right and so let's just practice that
let's not over overthink it let's just
practice it and see what that's going to
be like and it's gonna be really tough
y'all gonna have a different set of
challenges the same as if he had another
more visible disability the same as if
you had a more visible disability right
can you do those things because a part
of me wonders are you out are you not
interested in going through all of this
oh my goodness no i'm 100 in ah that
makes me happy good good good good
so
what if y'all reframed this
have a weekend of grief
write a letter to misophonia jimmy's
funny you ruined our life you suck we
hate you you've screwed up everything
and we're not gonna let you ruin our
marriage in fact we're gonna use this as
a springboard to be the best married
couple we could possibly be and we're
gonna raise a dope set of little crazy
saunas in the house we're gonna have an
awesome life and you're not taking this
from us
have a couple of days of grief
and then have a couple of days of
planning okay what does this look like
here's our reality the reality is you
can't do this job for 10 hours a day and
then come home and be a present husband
period right and how are we going to
work around that
you can't do this job 10 hours a day and
not have boundaries at work and come
home and be a present father one day
it's not the rea it's not the card so
you either you got to do something
different you get your job different
whatever
um
and then you all are going to start
working on new ways to communicate
together and i think if you all change
the oh my gosh we're just dragging
ourselves through this instead of
instead of that attitude turning and
facing it and running directly into the
middle of the darkness saying ha ha
we're turning on all the light switches
suckers we're going to be able to talk
right if you enter with that sort of
attitude we're gonna we're gonna storm
the gates of hell together
man this could be really fun because
you're gonna develop your own way of
communicating that nobody else has it's
gonna be a beautiful interactive way
um
so i that's that's the best i can do
please you'll go see a doctor together
who might give you some like oh yeah we
you can take this one thing or there's a
couple of supplements that help with the
auditory response system that help who
knows i don't know where any of that
stands
definitely worth going to see a medical
doctor and then as you all are working
through new ways of communicating it's
going to bring up old stories then you
may want to loot back and meet with a
counselor okay but i'm proud of you
thank you for loving that guy thank you
for being 100 all-in
she's got to live a different life now
that sounds so
so dismissive i just changed everything
it's cool
and yeah that's what you got to do we'll
be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they don't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john daloni show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
all right we're back let's take one more
let's go to chad and saint george man
hey chad
yeah how are we doing
we're doing good i'm glad to be honest
thanks man hey i drove through st george
last year on the way to a speaking
engagement
what a stunning
beautiful place
um i just continue the more i travel
across the country speaking to groups i
i
am just blown away by how beautiful this
country is and that st george area is
something else man it was stunning
stunning stunning and i almost died
that's another conversation all right so
what's up brother how can i help
uh okay so
i gotta give some backstory before i get
to my question or my advice
so
um
our father died uh the end of july oh
man i'm sorry what did he die of
uh
well it would be what you call your long
tail suicide oh no
basically drank and smoked himself into
he's not recovering
uh
he started failing i'm sorry brother
that's hard
hard hard
it's really hard
um
so every right after that um
my sister my younger sister she's two
years younger than me she's
i don't know if her if the drama
response to these things or
her and her husband decided that they
are now going to be swingers hey oh
oh yeah just a swanging
i know so
at first nobody really cut it everyone
was just kind of like wow this is just
midlife crisisy kind of stuff or
let me pause you
[Music]
if my wife came to me and said hey john
i got an idea
what about you and me just start
knocking around with the neighbors you
in and i was like i'm in honey
the last people on planet earth i would
call is my brother and sister
so how do you know that this is
happening and i'm not laughing at i'm
laughing with you like how would you
even know man did they announce this to
like at thanksgiving
they
this is kind of how she is she wants
she wanted the attention of it
um
and you know other people like we'll see
friends of our that i've known for years
middle school
or
all of a sudden they're friends and i
would have had no idea because they
don't advertise it but she does she
wants everyone to know
and it's just
weird
yeah
i'm being super weird man i i love my
sister with all my heart and there's
just parts of her life i don't want to i
don't want to know about that's cool
right but you know about your sister all
right so how can i help man yes
so
um
in doing all this her she has a 12 year
old son my nephews okay freaking raddest
kid ever
um he
has kind of just been
i mean
he is either locked in his room
when it happens
or
or he goes to other family members or
friends houses but now
everyone else has stopped taking him
because they feel like they're enabling
her to do this
or when he's at their house he's saying
he wants to be at my house with my boys
and wife
so
so now i'm stuck in the middle of
do i i feel like
by taking him it enables her to do that
it doesn't she's gonna dude she's
chat chat she's gonna do it anyway
i know you're not enabling her that's
where
you
take her out of the equation
take her completely out of the equation
okay you're taking care of a little 12
year old boy
that's it
all right okay and you're the kind of
you're the kind of guy that would take
care of a 12 year old boy because that's
who you are you're a good human being
you got your kids of your own you're a
guy who loves this community and loves
young people take care of that 12 year
old little boy you're not you're your
sister is going to figure out a way
around this until it burns itself out
and make no mistake it will it will lose
its smoke and steam and
the disco ball eventually stops spinning
right
and
so
it is what it is
or that 12 year old boy is really really
close to independence on his own
right right and he y'all are gonna all
lose him
and so yeah somebody's gotta love that
kid and care about him
yeah
okay
god can you imagine the book being
written in my head my mom locked me in
my room while she
hooked up with my dad's middle school i
mean my uncle's middle school friends
and my that's going to be a great a
great autobiography someday jeez
freaking yeah
well the weirdest part about this whole
thing is yeah tell me the weirdest part
because
so far
well the whole thing's weird but yeah
they're so they have an older son that's
22 23. he's my we have older sons and
they all kind of grew up and we took him
all the time too how old are you um
i'm 43. how old is your sister
she's uh 42.
for 41. i've had in my head this whole
conversation you were like 25.
this makes this whole thing way more
disturbing go ahead go ahead right just
like 40 year olds just cruising like
what's up all right so yeah all right so
they have an older older son okay yeah
there's been older son he's in his in
the early 20s um and
apparently
he is the one that suggested to them
that they do this
why not they let him into that part of
their life like why not i don't think
he's doing it with them but
to have that conversation
dude she already told her brother so why
not bring your kids in she probably sat
down all the pets just said them all in
a row and told them to
yeah dude who knows who knows man i
um yeah a 22 year old's a grown up and
he's old enough to have his own
boundaries and to make his own choices
and decisions it is what it is
um right yeah when my son's 22 we're
gonna well i mean i'll share everything
with my son but we're not talking about
that
because i love him
you know what i mean i don't know i
don't want to melt him
but
here's the thing man
you have to decide in your in your heart
and mind this me being serious now
um
the people you choose to associate with
and this is hard because she's your
sister
and
there's some point when she becomes not
your sister
but and i think i mean this we talk
about swinging and all that kind of
stuff and we can make jokes about it
this is bigger than that you've lost
your sister not just because she's
sleeping with other dudes and her
husband's sleeping other women that's
not it
um she is searching so hard
to be seen and to be known and to not
feel um dead in her own skin
that ways she can fire off firecrackers
underneath her own skin
to prop herself up is to go get her
heart rate racing for 30 minutes with a
stranger to
try to get a rise out of you and the
other family members look at me look at
me look at me look at me and that's a
little girl in that little body saying
somebody tell me tell me you love me
somebody see me right so the whole thing
is heartbreaking and it's easy to point
to the one thing that's like
swinging just because that sounds funny
right um but you could point to that but
this is a this is the story of a brother
who's losing his little sister
yeah right and that sucks and it's
heartbreaking
and it puts you in a position to say
here's my boundary
while you're trying to figure out love
this is what this is what connecting
with me looks like and if you want to
opt out i'm going to be heartbroken but
you're free to do that
because this is how i'm going to raise
my kids so i'm going to raise my family
this is how i'm going to fill in the
blank right
right um
and by the way if she circles back and
joins the fold and
and i say that like with in it with a
smirk on my face like like if she
circles back and says hey dude i kind of
lost it and her and her husband she used
to still do this once a month they
should
i still wouldn't have a problem with her
eating dinner at my house that's my
sister my kids are all gonna know yep
that's that's aunt so-and-so
uh my kids called my sister uh tialoka
they don't know her name my sister gave
them that name that's spanish for a
crazy aunt they gave like my kids think
that my sister's name is teoloka so i
mean we they just know like yeah that's
aunt so-and-so right they get that um
this is about i've got to draw
boundaries and my guess is she's talking
in ways that you don't want around your
kids you're worried about the fact that
she's locking her their 12 year old son
12 is old my son's 12. right locking
this kid that knows what's going on in
this house in his room i mean that whole
thing is a mess man
and so this is about a brother who's
losing his little sister this is about a
guy trying to take care of a 12 year old
kid let's take all the take all the big
flashy stuff and the signs in the oh my
gosh and
take all that off the table man grieve
the loss of your sister come up with
your boundaries there and then love and
take care of this little 12 year old kid
and if it crosses over into hey she
locked him in there for a day
call cps
yeah call the authorities because you
can't you can't lock it you can't lock a
child in a room and not give them food
not give them water all that kind of
stuff right yeah well he i don't i don't
know how many times that's happened but
i do know that like hey here's a xbox
have fun in there don't come out you
know right right right
and again that's different than i put a
padlock on the door
while we're in here
and i'm gonna put a padlock on the door
you can't come out there's difference
there right but
um ultimately
you have to grieve the loss of your
sister
and
you have to make some choices am i going
to accept this new behavior am i going
to accept this new relationship that
she's put back that she's choosing to or
am i going to draw the boundaries for me
and my family and
how and when am i going to love this 12
year old little boy
and that's i wouldn't let any of the
other nonsense clouded okay it's just
going to make it more complicated you
can also tell her
um
when she's like oh yeah and then last
weekend you can stop her
and say i do not want to hear about your
sexual exploits you're my sister stop
yeah don't give it any any attention
she'll say it and i just
she wants the attention i'm not giving
it to her well
but she can see your eye crinkles she
can feel the energy in the room change
and that's power that feels powerful
there's something about stopping that
conversation as it's happening with a
firm boundary
right stop stop talking about your sex
life with me i do not want to know
period and let that tension hang let
that because that is you reclaiming the
room energy that you recrea reclaiming
your boundaries and it changes the
dynamic of it oh my gosh you think
you're so much better than me didn't say
that i said stop talking about your sex
life with me
period right and with that level of
authority and force and it has a way of
of really pushing back on people who
just like to lob fireworks and grenades
at people and be like oh yeah look what
i'm doing look what i'm doing could care
less
do not tell me that
if you continue to tell me that you are
choosing to not be in a relationship
with me and i hope you don't choose that
because i like hanging out with you
and now she owns all the cards moving
forward because you have put your
boundary in concrete right and that's an
awesome awesome thing it's a gift to her
brother and it's a gift to you and your
family thank you for being a guy that
takes care of the little kids in your
community and in your family it's
beautiful we'll be right back
[Music]
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show the song of the day is a
choose your own adventure
pretty excited about this
behind door number one this is the
boomers song so if you want to hear the
boomer version just stay put and if you
want to uh
go to the the millennial version just
hit the you know fast forward about 15
20 seconds and listen for the
and that's how you know to turn the page
and uh here we go so for the boomers the
song of the day is
from the dire straits sultans of swing
and it goes like this
you got a shiver in the dark it's
raining in the park but meantime south
of the river you stop and you hold
everything a band is blowing dixie
double four time you feel all right when
you hear the music ring now step inside
but you don't see too many faces
[Music]
coming in and out of the rain to hear
the jazz go down competition in other
places give your kid an xbox and shut
that it's not really in the song all
right the next song is from sia
the lyrics to her masterpiece i don't
think it's a masterpiece chandelier and
it goes like this
oh boy y'all gonna get me in trouble
party girls don't get hurt can't feel
anything when i when will i learn i push
it down push it down
i'm the one for a good time call phone's
blowing up ringing my doorbell i feel
the love feel the love one two three one
two three drink this doesn't sound like
a great healthy song so i'm back till i
lose count i'm gonna swing from the
chandelier
[Music]
that's what we do on the show we swing
from the chandeliers we'll see you next
time
coming up on the next episode so in the
process of trying to frame up my
question neatly which is
kind of difficult yeah i was gonna say
disordered eating and addiction are
never never uh yeah it's summed up
neatly so give me the whole messy mess
so my mom
she's been married three times she just
goes from boyfriend to boyfriend she
likes to spend time with my two-year-old
which is which is great but the
boyfriend is always around in some way
either he lives there or she has to do
something nope
i'll solve that one for you answer is no
[Music]